[Musique]
cette deuxième journée marathon commence
à ébène à citi de maurice et dans
l'équipe de l'agencé française de
développement
martin guichard fait partie des contrats
uniques d'insertion de la zone océan
indien
aujourd'hui cette agence convient le
département autour de la table du
ministère de l'environnement
en fait compte je lui posais la question
mais pourquoi tu es là et elle disparaît
c'est un hasard mais en même temps je
savais pas que je pouvais travailler
dans l'idaho ciani et à maurice donc ça
veut dire que là il ya quelque chose qui
se fait cette opportunité je les ai
découverts par hasard je suis bien des
rivières des ponts de l'eau potable
d'eaux usées de l'eau agricole ce
territoire d'un million trois cent mille
habitants compte les mêmes
problématiques de l'eau que notre île
mais actuellement pas d'observatoire qui
centralise la connaissance on a
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle un office
home office de voilà la plus value du
département des années d' expertise de
cette institution
de quoi impulser de nouvelles relations
dans le nom texte changement climatique
il ya beaucoup des problématiques dans
le secteur et ça concerne en termes de
quantité et qualité et nous apprenons
que la réunion a beaucoup d'expérience
si nous avons une expérience dans les
secteurs et dans les secteurs de
l'énergie que nous avons travaillé en
étroite collaboration avec la région
répéter ça dans l'eau direction ensuite
l'université ou un usage scientifique de
ses connaissances se profile contre bute
sait faire ensemble et en même temps
profiter bain de tout ce génie de le
lydia ou ciani pour aborder la vie de
demain peu ce qui va agir comme un
groupe de réflexion et il ya des
expertises dans la région et peur pour
avoir une communauté de recherche et
pour pouvoir partager c'est l'esprit de
partage et aussi de voir bénéficier
désormais des échanges des connaissances
dans l'art et surtout c'est un projet
global
c'est un projet ambitieux et en même
temps aujourd'hui ça s'appellera
l'observatoire de l'eau mais c'est pas
juste des chiffres
ça va être comment prévenir l'avenir
le réchauffement climatique est là et la
population ne regarde pas le
réchauffement climatique elle dit les
élus ont-ils anticiper ce qui va nous
arriver et c'est là aussi que le
challenge l'anticipation la journée
s'enchaînent par la rencontre de la
présidente de la chambre d'agriculture
un beau moment des changes pour le
conseiller départemental mais également
maire de bras-panon
ça pourrait être un exemple stasiak à
maurice nous a pas tendre non seulement
tomates cerises de d'égypte ou même de
plus loin et je sais que vous en
produisent et à la réunion mais pourquoi
aller chercher aussi loin
ce sera quoi l'avenir mais ce sera un
marché comme en fruits et légumes
savoir-faire ingénierie entre déjà
réunion maurice on est le plus proche
d'un jour les comores l'autre jour
l'afrique de sud c'est un marché qui
aujourd'hui
comment india océanique est en vente
pour nos populations la proximité avec
maurice oblige aujourd'hui à travailler
en commun une économie sud-sud que cette
coopération soit facilitée
[Musique]